elle a des lunettes mais c'est elle
on a parlé ensemble 10 minutes
je pense que
c'est autrement Ellie on était dans un
mètre carré ensemble
il vous observe il vous Épît vous filme
vous photographies il travaille
peut-être pour vos voisins vos proches
votre conjoint votre patron rien ne
semble les arrêter mais des affaires des
scandales ont révélé leurs pratiques
Bruno Gaccio l'auteur des Guignols de
l'Info écouté prise en filature
Olivier Besancenot espionné pour le
compte du fabricant du pistolet Taser
les ordinateurs de Greenpeace surveillés
par une mystérieuse officine au centre
de ces scandales des détectives privés
une profession décrié qui aujourd'hui
souhaite sortir de l'ombre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
proche banlieue de la région parisienne
Raphaël Martini est détective privé ou
plutôt agent de recherche privée c'est
le nouveau terme légal pour désigner sa
profession pour des raisons de sécurité
et de vie privée Martigny restera
anonyme
il travaille en indépendant pour des
agences de détective et ce jour-là il a
rendez-vous chez helicohen qui dirige
une agence de recherche privée réputée
très particulière il suffit de démontrer
d'apporter des éléments sur la véracité
du temps
qui est destiné ou qui est on va dire le
temps qui est nécessaire pour faire un
parcours une mission pour apporter une
preuve déterminante dans un procès sur
les embouteillages en roulant à vitesse
normale
respectant les limitations évidemment
pas qu'on a fait ça on aura des éléments
il y a plus ensuite on verra si on
poursuit
je te tiens il s'agit d'une
contre-inquiète pénale une femme jugée
en assise à 18 ans de prison pour le
meurtre de l'amende de son mari a-t-on
beaucoup du résultat de cette enquête en
effet son jugement pour être remis en
cause
si le temps du trajet qu'il l'accuse ne
peut se dérouler en 45 minutes numéro 14
8h44 donc on se prépare à y aller
filmer photographier dictée ses faits et
gestes tout noté afin de rendre le
meilleur rapport tous ces petits détails
non l'air de rien mais au bout de cette
mission peut-être qu'une femme sera
innocentée le rapport que Martigny va
rendre sera transmis aux avocats qui
pourront le présenter devant la justice
mais pour que ce rapport soit accepté
par un juge rien ne doit être laissé au
hasard
9h28 normalement c'est la fin du
parcours c'est l'heure d'arrivée
du de la personne sur son lieu de
travail
[Musique]
donc conclusion conclusion n'y est pas
du tout pour le moment on est très en
retard et donc c'est important qu'on le
fasse plusieurs fois des horaires
différents
parce que on pourrait
argumenter du fait que
voilà on aurait fait qu'une fois le
temps de trajet que ça veut rien dire
que
à l'époque il y avait moins de monde sur
le trajet ou voilà et du coup dire
vous ne trouvez pas que ce trajet est
et
faisable que en par exemple en 1h30 ou
en deux heures c'est un peu comme entre
guillemets le même principe que
des scientifiques qui vont devoir
répéter une expérience pour prouver que
ça marche
une fois ne suffit pas
ce type de mission particulière Martini
on a déjà fait beaucoup bien loin de nos
références cinématographiques ou
littéraires le privé d'aujourd'hui ne
sirote pas le whisky des pieds sur le
bureau et le pistolet sous le bras
c'est pas comme dans les films
c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
on n'est pas sur des enquêtes
avec multiples rebondissements grand
méchant armé etc etc c'est pas du tout
le
c'est pas du tout le fond du métier et
justement quel est c'est quoi le fond du
métier c'est très large c'est
c'est
la chronique ordinaire de la nature
humaine
ça veut dire ça veut dire tout ce qui
est du domaine de de l'afro du mensonge
de tout ce qui relève
des conflits entre personnes
désormais les constats d'adultère ne
représentent plus qu’une toute petite
partie de l'activité des privées
aujourd'hui avec la compétition
économique les tensions sociales la
pression médiatique ils enquêtent pour
le compte d'industriels sur la
concurrence déloyale le vol dans les
entreprises ou encore font du
renseignement économique
[Musique]
changement de cap dans la profession les
nouveaux privés doivent être formés bien
formés
c'est à Melun que l'on forme les futurs
agents de recherche privée cette
institut de droit et d'économie est le
seul campus universitaire français a
dispenser deux formations
professionnelles un diplôme
universitaire mais aussi une licence qui
permet d'ouvrir une agence en ce jour de
rentrée universitaire 750 étudiants sont
présents
parmi eux 30 ont un profil particulier
30 veulent devenir agent de recherche
privée mais en ce jour de rentrée
l'ancienne promotion termine elle sa
formation par une épreuve décisive un
grand oral une épreuve que Guillaume 35
ans vient de passer avec succès pour
être gérant de son propre cabinet il
veut rester anonyme car il travaille
souvent en infiltration et ne veut pas
être reconnu aujourd'hui des lois qui se
font qui évoluent tous les jours
notre travail encore une fois c'est de
répondre à une problématique quoi
d'apporter des éléments de travailler en
collaboration avec des avocats des
huissiers les magistrats et
on dans cette formation aujourd'hui on
nous recadre bien par rapport à ça
dans la salle d'examen des spécialistes
du droit mais aussi des figures du
métier qui ne badinent pas avec
l'éthique d'une profession qui parfois
prend des libertés avec la loi en veste
blanche celui qui représente la
déontologie du métier Christian Borniche
40 ans dans le métier on le surnomme
l'encyclopédie il est à l'origine de ces
formations universitaires et avec lui on
ne plaisante pas la candidate vient de
faire un stage dans une agence de
recherche privée on lui a confié une
mission et aujourd'hui elle doit
justifier son rapport d'enquête
la demande du temps d'essayer de
déterminer l'origine enfin d'un
coulage de marchandises en provenance
d'un magasin qui est situé dans un
centre commercial il se posait des
questions sur trois protagonistes qui
étaient le directeur du magasin le
directeur régional et annexe salarié et
donc je me suis aperçue que l'ex salarié
vivait en fait avec le directeur de
magasin est-ce que vous ne considérez
pas que ça rentre dans sa vie privée ça
déjà d'une part
alors est-ce que cette information a été
retranscrite
aux clients
ça avait été écrit il y a plusieurs
reprises des problèmes de respect de la
vie privée dans ce dans ce dossier n'est
pas précisé si les salariés c'est le
règlement intérieur de l'entreprise
prévoyez ces contrôles ou pas il n'est
pas précisé non plus qu'elle était
l'objet du rapport est-ce que c'était
pour engager des poursuites
disciplinaires contre le salarié ou
engager des poursuites pénales car la
procédure n'est pas du tout la même
alors dans un cas votre rapport peut
être utilisé dans l'autre non que le
directeur de l'agence les fait c'est son
problème
s'il méconnait des dispositions
juridiques et s'ils sont clients a des
problèmes ça sera c'est souci personnels
ce que je vous reproche simplement c'est
de ne pas avoir soulevé les problèmes
juridiques c'est-à-dire voilà là il y a
quand même un problème
on n'a pas à dire que bon on peut dire
que ils sont à la même adresse on n'a
pas donné des explications sur le fait
qu'ils vivent ensemble ça ne regarde
personne dans quel cas pouvez-vous
prendre une photo et la transmettre et à
qui vous devez la transmettre alors on
peut la transmettre soit directement
enfin au Conseil de la dame si c'est par
trop enfin par rapport à la bouteille
c'est dans l'intérêt aussi des droits de
la défense d'accord
par contre effectivement une image
normalement n'a pas le droit sans
consentement la personne de la France
d'accord c'est ce que je voulais vous
faire dire c'est à dire que lorsque pour
les besoins d'une preuve vous pouvez
prendre une photographie sur la voie
publique mais que cette photographie ne
doit pas être remise au client elle doit
être remise à l'avocat du client de
façon à être transmise directement au
magistrats et dans ces cas précis il n'y
a pas de violation de la vie privée au
terme de la jurisprudence Christian vous
avez non c'est bon
respecter la loi être dans la légalité
c'est ce que doit apprendre la nouvelle
génération d'enquêteurs privés depuis
1998 230 diplômés sont sortis de
l'Université de Melun
les enseignements qui sont dispensés à
l'Université Paris 21 double d'une part
des enseignements juridiques
essentiellement tourner sur l'exercice
de la profession et des enseignements
techniques alors les enseignements
juridiques c'est bien entendu tout ce
que les enquêteurs ou les futurs ou les
candidats la profession doivent
connaître pour ne pas commettre d'un
père pour ne pas franchir la ligne jaune
ou la ligne blanche maintenant
de façon à exercer leur activité en
toute légalité mais aussi en toute
sécurité
et les enseignements techniques se sont
toutes les méthodes légales
d'investigation donc on va leur
apprendre des techniques telles que la
surveillance et la filature
l'apprentissage de la photographie
l'utilisation de moyens informatiques
des bases de données par exemple
puisqu'on parle de base de données les
informations que nous transmettons à nos
clients doivent obligatoirement être
cryptés car si elles ne sont pas
cryptées n'importe qui pourrait les
intercepter et cela constitue un délit
pénal au passage 50 prisons et 300.000
euros d'amende connaître ses droits et
ses devoirs tel est l'enjeu de la
formation à une profession qui attire
des jeunes venus de tous les horizons
retour chez helicoen patron d'une agence
qui fait travailler plusieurs enquêteurs
parmi eux une stagiaire encore étudiante
à Melun Céline a 38 ans elle a travaillé
dans la sécurité et il y a 3 ans elle a
décidé de se reconvertir un parcours
très personnel car un jour pour régler
un problème dans sa vie privée elle a du
jouer au détective cette envie de
devenir enquêteur privé ou agent
recherche privée elle est née où elle
est née de allez je dois l'avouer de ma
propre expérience oui parce que dans la
vie de tous les jours on a on fait des
actes des actes juridiques tout le temps
constamment sans s'en apercevoir on sait
pas et il y a parfois ben des problèmes
quand ça fonctionne pas alors on
forcément on s'adresse à des avocats on
s'adresse à des huissiers et on se rend
compte que les huissiers les avocats
nous demandent des éléments de preuve
donc eux ont besoin pour notre propre
défense et que là les éléments de preuve
et ben il faut aller les chercher et
alors ben
pour ma part j'avais pas les moyens de
faire appel à un enquêteur de droit
privé donc j'ai téléchargé moi-même et
c'est comme ça que Céline a pris goût au
métier aller chercher des preuves
enquêter faire le pavé le bitume pour
des filatures Céline Koné bien
qu'étudiante elle travaille toujours à
la sécurité ferroviaire en région
Île-de-France mais une fois le diplôme
en poche elle espère bien être agent de
recherche privée et travaillé pour une
agence dans ce métier la patience est
une qualité première aujourd'hui la
mission de Céline est d'obtenir des
informations sur une femme dont le
conjoint veut se séparer donc ça c'est
qui ça c'est la personne qu'on doit
surveiller la femme recherchée menace
son mari de porter plainte pour abandon
alors qu'elle serait handicapée et
qu'elle aurait du mal à se déplacer seul
problème pour le mari cette femme n'a
aucun handicap et il voudrait en
apporter la preuve devant un juge
en fait l'idée c'est de déterminer
comment elle se déplace si elle est
handicapée dépendante
elle est moins corpulente et elle est un
petit peu plus grande
voilà entre une photo et
une personne
de pied
qui évolue dans la rue
il y a des fois des grosses surprises
notamment chez les femmes qui peuvent
changer d'apparence comme de chemise
à la recherche de la moindre information
du détail qui fera la différence pour
arriver à identifier cette femme Céline
va rappeler hélicoen
je suis sur place dit j'ai oublié de te
demander à approximativement combien il
mesure
d'accord sinon bah je vais essayer
d'aller voir le monsieur essayez chez
lui il y a un inflation du coup on verra
je préférais tout à l'heure le monsieur
c'est l'employeur de la femme recherchée
obtenir des informations auprès de cet
homme serait un plus
[Musique]
Céline va y aller au culot en sonnant
chez lui elle va recourir à une petite
ruse sans sortir de la légalité comme
elle l'a appris à l'université
bonjour bonjour je m'appelle Sophie
nirood et je voudrais savoir si vous
pouvez me recevoir et me parler des 30
secondes
mais il y a pas de souci monsieur je
reviendrai dans un quart d'heure merci
pour cette prise de contact Céline s'est
présentée en donnant le nom de Sophie
sous quelle forme tu t'es présenté là
l'interphone c'est la différence avec
une
usurpation d'identité ou là dans un
contexte précis pour un objectif précis
on a enfin le nom de quelqu'un qui
existe ça c'est une usurpation
d'identité tandis que là non j'ai
surtout
l'idée c'était pas c'était pas c'était
de pas dire mon nom à moi quoi
un quart d'heure plus tard l'employeur
de la femme recherchée ne répond plus à
l'interphone pas de chance
Céline décide alors de se déplacer au
domicile de sa cible
identifier la personne recherchée et
l'objectif de la journée prise de notes
trajet photographie des lieux ne rien
oublier restez vigilant toutes ces notes
serviront au rapport de cette mission
mais pour le moment déterminez comment
la personne recherchée se déplace ça ce
n'est pas gagné céline est entrée dans
le hall de l'immeuble elle va maintenant
tenter de monter dans les étages et pour
cela elle va sonner à plusieurs
interphones pour essayer de se faire
ouvrir la porte
et miracle sans que personne ne lui
demande rien quelqu'un lui ouvre la
porte
et dans le couloir surprise
Céline croise la femme recherchée et
visiblement elle marche son béquille le
contact avec la cible est établi Céline
fait son rapport téléphonique
médiatement à hélicoël au 19 tu sais de
la deuxième adresse
interphone et tout et tout mon moi j'ai
sonné plein plein de fois la porte s'est
ouverte une dame qui m'a croisée et qui
me dit c'est vous qui avez sonné je lui
dis non non non
je l'ai identifié c'était elle mission
remplie visiblement la femme se déplace
normalement le conjoint va en être
informé et pourra alors engager une
procédure de divorce l'esprit plus en
paix d'ici là Céline va faire des photos
de sa cible pour compléter son rapport
[Musique]
Paris les beaux quartiers rendez-vous
boulevard de Courcelles dans le plus
ancien cabinet de détective privé de
France un cabinet fondé en 1924 par
l'illustre René farallik l'homme qui a
arrêté l'andru le tueur en série qui a
défrayé la chronique il y a près d'un
siècle
dès l'âge de 6 ans
Eric Quenet prêtait main forte à son
père sur toutes sortes de missions
notamment les surveillances à l'époque
personne ne se méfiait d'un gamin de six
ans qui préférait faire des filatures
plutôt que d'aller à l'école le cabinet
a évolué avec de nouvelles méthodes et
approches d'investigation
Eric Quenet est en recherche permanente
de nouveaux marchés et de nouveaux
talents et à l'Université de Melun il a
trouvé une perle rare parmi la nouvelle
génération de détective en formation
cette jeune femme genre première de la
classe est spécialisée dans les œuvres
d'art pour des raisons de sécurité elle
garde elle aussi l'anonymat la notion
d'investigation dans les affaires de de
de vol d'objets d'art j'avais une
approche qui était tout à fait
classique de l'investigation etc
Christelle m'a permis en fait de pouvoir
identifier qu'il y avait de nouveaux
besoins que les collectionneurs étaient
susceptibles de pouvoir nous photocopies
de nos sociétés sur des choses tout à
fait nouvelles mais que je n'aurais pas
pu
sans son expérience proposée aux clients
donc conjugaison des compétences qui
permettent de faire naître un nouveau
produit quel regard portez-vous sur le
fait d'apprendre quelque chose à une
personne qui a plus de 30 ans
d'expérience
moi j'irai pas jusqu'à
considérer lui avoir appris quelque
chose mais plus une ouverture sur une
nouvelle discipline sur un nouveau champ
d'activité
Christelle se distingue en matière
d'investigation on sent qu'elle va
au-delà de ce que l'on peut retrouver
chez la plupart des stagiaires je ne dis
pas que les autres stagiaires ne font
pas bien leur métier mais elle a une
particularité qui fait qu'elle se
démarque des autres très nettement
ouvrir de nouveaux marchés ce
professionnel est aussi redorer le
blason d'un métier longtemps éclaboussé
par les scandales ce sont les nouveaux
mots d'ordre d'une profession qui peut à
peu s'organise en dehors de l'Université
de Melun il existe un autre moyen pour
devenir agent de recherche privé et
ouvrir une agence ça s'appelle la VAE la
validation des acquis et des expériences
depuis 2002 ce dispositif permet
l'obtention de tout ou d'une partie de
la certification du diplôme
universitaire à condition de réussir un
grand oral
les candidats ont des profils variés
anciens banquiers reconvertis dans le
recouvrement de créances policier à la
retraite ou encore un détective privé en
exercice qui souhaitait être diplômé
chaque candidat a déboursé près de 450
euros pour passer devant ce jury composé
d'enseignants de l'Université de Melun
des examinateurs qui ne laissent rien
passer
maintenant que vous êtes présentés aux
vacances à vous interroger
hier je les laisse faire mon
collègueulasse
[Musique]
l'anglais c'était une simple mise en
bouche passons maintenant aux choses
sérieuses pour tester les compétences
juridiques du candidat les examinateurs
vont avoir recours à des mises en
situation ils vont ainsi demander aux
candidats de se mettre dans la peau d'un
chef d'entreprise confronté à un
problème avec l'un de ses employés
d'avoir une concurrence déloyale ou
d'aller sur des sites de pornographiques
pendant le temps de travail est-ce que
vous pouvez consulter ces mails est-ce
que vous pouvez consulter son ordinateur
j'ai pas le cas personnellement dans le
sens où moi j'ai pas de collaborateur
aujourd'hui je sais qu'il y a des moyens
de tracer effectivement et vous êtes
certain vous y a pas une atteinte
quelque part
[Musique]
au niveau à partir du moment
au travail
en matière de tant que téléphonique je
pense que c'est c'est lui un petit peu à
la déontologie du métier maintenant
effectivement il est de par notre métier
on a la possibilité effectivement de
procéder à des enquêtes téléphoniques
sans se présenter donc ça c'est une
chose après usurpé une identité ou
quelque chose comme ça moi je sais que
personnellement le fait
des résultats facilement on obtient des
résultats
au niveau de tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est administration publique donc il y a
un droit donc au niveau des mairies par
exemple qui permet à tout requérant de
pouvoir consulter les actes d'état civil
et de se faire des livres des actes
d'état civils de naissance ou de mariage
en filiation au niveau de
ça marche très bien ça marche très bien
ensuite effectivement après on peut
faire des fax on a des fax donc qui nous
présentent effectivement où l'on se
présente sans usurpation où on laisse
nos corps d'aimer téléphoniques
éventuellement et après c'est pareil au
niveau des listes électorales donc on
sert essentiellement des taxes légaux de
toute façon la profession c'est pas on
n'a pas de plus de droit que les autres
donc on a des citoyens lambda avec les
mêmes droits civils que les autres donc
les candidats se succèdent et cet
après-midi mieux vaut connaître les lois
sur le bout des doigts surtout que les
lois qui encadrent la profession
d'agents de recherche privée sont en
train de changer
si tu veux continuer
que s'est-il passé le 23 février 2009
dans notre profession le 23 février 2009
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors
à cette question piège le candidat reste
sans voix
je l'ai lu déjà
c'est la nouvelle loi de la
manifestation de la loi du 12 février 83
le candidat hésite se trompe dans les
dates à sa décharge il est vrai que la
législation encadrant la profession et
tout sauf simple le 23 février 2009
paraissait au Journal officiel la
dernière mouture d'une loi datant de
1983 modifiée en 2003 mais qui n'a
jamais été complètement appliqué
résultat tout le monde à présent doit
avoir son agrément préfectoral afin
d'exercer la profession
objectif assainir la profession autre
objectif stopper les dérives comme par
exemple quand un détective privé obtient
une information auprès d'un ami policier
ce qui est illégal
on va partir de l'hypothèque comme
détective privé que vous êtes en
confiture et puis vous suivez une
voiture
vous prenez le numéro de plaque
la question c'est et vous avez besoin de
savoir quel est le propriétaire de cette
voiture toute cette moto
comment vous faites sont des câbles bien
spécifiques on peut en faire la demande
pour lever le secret professionnel on va
dire vous êtes sur cette mission qui est
quand même apparemment chaude et puis
vous avez besoin de ça tout de suite
pourquoi n'avez vous pas un copain de
votre service mais on peut le faire
maintenant c'est interdit
je peux je peux pourquoi je vous dirai
je vous dirai non c'est une question
je sais que évidemment le réseau de
relations dans cette profession est très
très importante maintenant
c'est pas trop conseillé dans la mesure
où le fonctionnaire ou la personne qui
va vous donner l'information peut lui
être directement inquiété et bon vous
êtes déjà demandé ce genre de
renseignements bien sûr vous l'avez fait
sur
l'hypothèse ou un nouveau collègue quand
vous appelez votre collègue pour lui
demander d'identification de cette
plaque qu'est-ce qu'il peut risquer
hormis la sanction la sanction pénale
donc je peux pas vous dire exactement ce
que c'est mais je pense que c'est quoi
[Musique]
d'être inquiéter aussi par rapport le
candidat ne connaît pas bien la loi
l'accord option de fonctionnaires est
passible de prison jusqu'à 10 ans
d'emprisonnement avec en plus une amende
qui peut atteindre 150000 euros
dans le jargon des détectives privés
obtenir un renseignement illégalement
d'un fonctionnaire de police ça
s'appelle la Tricoche et la pratique
serait très répandue merci Monsieur pour
la plupart des candidats c'est la douche
froide la validation des acquis et des
expériences n'est pas une simple
formalité
assez assez pointu
je pense que je n'y étais pas assez
préparé et
il va un peu plus loin que les acquis
même je vois au niveau de la profession
de policier de mes qualités d'APG ça va
quand même beaucoup plus loin donc je
pense qu'il y a un travail plus poussé
plus poussé de recherche un peu plus un
peu plus poussées à effectuer de ma part
des cinq candidats qui ont passé ce
jour-là le grand oral aucun n'a été reçu
et ils ont tous été invités à suivre les
cours de l'Université de Melun pour
Didier roche détective privé et en
charge de l'enseignement c'est une
évidence le métier a changé et personne
ne peut plus s'improviser détective
privé sans formation
des grandes mutations économiques de la
France notre pays était
était
ont laissé place à un métier
orienté vers quelque chose qui s'appelle
la preuve et nous avons toujours pensé
que
cette connaissance juridiques est à
nécessaire pour exercer ce métier et
bien nous en a pris
puisque l'Union fédérale des enquêteurs
de droit privé a largement anticipé sur
la réglementation qui est venu bien
après et aujourd'hui nous sommes fiers
de constater que plus d'une centaine
d'enquêteurs qui sont issus de notre
faculté sont installés en France exerce
le métier dans la dignité dans la
connaissance
la dignité et la connaissance ce
discours est martelé par les enseignants
de Melun il faut dire qu'ils ont
beaucoup à faire pour changer l'image
d'une profession qui s'est illustrée
récemment dans des scandales
retentissants
comme celui qui est survenu lors de la
sortie d'un livre un livre écrit par un
ancien espion de la DGSE Pierre Martinet
en 2002 Pierre Martinet se reconvertit
il est engagé par Vivendi comme
détective privé afin de lutter contre
les décodeurs pirates de la chaîne de
télévision Canal+ mais très vite sa
mission se serait orientée vers
l'espionnage d'une des figues
emblématiques de la chaîne Bruno Gaccio
Pierre Martinet aurait reçu l'ordre de
fouiller dans la vie privée de
l'animateur vedette une affaire toujours
en instruction dont le procès doit avoir
lieu en 2010 en attendant Martinez a eu
le temps de réfléchir très facilement
vous demander un renseignement un petit
d'abord un petit renseignement sur un
salarié de la boîte c'est très facile
un puis deux puis trois on s'en rend pas
bien compte et puis petit à petit on est
pris dans une tonnerie on est pris dans
un
une guignolerie excusez-moi l'expression
et puis on arrive à faire on arrive à
aller faire de la filature sur une
personne médiatique qui ne sert à rien
un ancien des services ou un ancien flip
bien souvent on lui demande quelque
chose il pose pas vraiment la question
parce que il a cette il a l'habitude de
cloisonner tout ce qui fait donc il a
vécu comme ça pendant 20 ans donc il se
retrouve dans une société privée qui te
fait aussi donc ça le choque pas
vraiment jusqu'au moment où on s'en rend
compte et on stoppe tout
c'est pour ça qu'il faut se préparer à
la reconversion entre guillemets même si
on ne décide de continuer à faire ce
métier qui est passionnant
autre exemple aujourd'hui connu d'action
illégale
ces images ont été tournées par des
détectives privés et elle concerne l'une
des affaires les plus sensibles
l'affaire optimum du nom d'une société
fabricant des meubles en bois blanche
l'affaire est très délicate car la
directrice de l'époque n'était autre que
Laurence Parisot aujourd'hui présidente
du Medef
une laguna en 2005 la société optimum
avait commandité une enquête car elle
suspectait des vols au sein de son
entreprise
la direction voulait connaître toutes
les entrées et sorties des employés
seul souci cette surveillance réalisée
par des détectives privés ce serait
poursuivi jusqu'au domicile des employés
si cette affaire est connue c'est grâce
à un livre choc intitulé allez-y on vous
couvre qui révèle les surveillances des
salariés de l'entreprise l'auteur
Patrick Battendier après 22 ans dans la
gendarmerie il s'était reconverti en
tant qu'agent de recherche privée et
travaillait pour crawl une société
spécialisée dans le renseignement
économique selon battantier à l'époque
optimum a eu recours à des privés pour
éviter une enquête de police officielle
la stratégie à ce moment-là des
dirigeants d'optimum et de rester
discrets sur ces sur ses vols parce que
je pense qu'ils sont déjà engagés dans
une stratégie de revente et que faire
intervenir à ce moment là l'État n'est
pas quelque chose qui leur qui les
effleurent pour cette raison mais
également aussi parce que certainement
ils n'ont pas pu encore concrètement et
complètement analyser d'où pouvait
provenir c'est c'est manque dimanche ça
aurait pu être une erreur comptable tout
simplement ça aurait pu être des erreurs
en comptabilité ça aurait pu être des
écarts de stocks qui s'expliquaient
autrement que par des vols et je crois
que c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
n'a pas voulu saisir les services de
journaux de police quelle aura
effectivement très bien pu saisir tout à
fait naturellement mais la question est
surtout de savoir pourquoi saisir crawl
plutôt que de servir n'importe quel
agent privé de recherche sachant que
crawl est quand même une structure qui
donne plus dans l'intelligence
économique
qui a un simple agent de recherche qui
était tout à fait capable de résoudre
cette problématique
si Patrick battantier dérange c'est
qu'il révèle qu'au-delà des agences de
recherche privée il y a ce que l'on
nomme dans le jargon lieu l'intelligence
économique en fait des agences de
renseignements privés qui collectent des
informations utiles aux acteurs
économiques grâce entre autres aux
détectives privés
le leader mondial de l'UE se nomme crawl
60 bureaux dans le monde répartis dans
plus de 29 pays fondé en 1972 par un
ancien de la CIA la réputation de la
société de renseignements n'est plus à
faire nous avons tenté de rencontrer les
dirigeants de crawl et à 5 reprises nos
rendez-vous ont été tous reportés ou
annulés
les hautes sphères financières ont
recours à crawl que ce soit dans
l'évaluation des entreprises la
vérification de CV ou la surveillance
des fusions acquisitions des compétences
qui pouvaient plaire à la direction de
la société optimum
je pense que là encore elle voulait la
confidentialité totale et voulait aussi
la puissance que pouvait avoir crawl
quand au moyen qui pouvaient être
engagés quoi qu'il en soit crawl moi m'a
demandé donc de une période de trois
jours au mois de 3 ou 4 jours au mois de
novembre 2005 d'aller me positionner
avec une équipe devant la société et
bien évidemment de filmer les entrées
les sorties du personnel de la société
et de filmer l'intérieur également de
l'entreprise pour savoir ce qui s'y
passait comment les camions qui
livraient comme ils étaient checker
comment les marchandises pouvaient être
chargées déplacées à l'intérieur même de
la société
Crolles le leader de l'intelligence
économique ne ferait pas dans la
demi-mesure et battant dit accuse bien
souvent ces puissants donneurs d'ordre
lui aurait demandé d'enfreindre la loi
assez assez régulièrement d'avoir les
intitulés bancaires
des personnes ciblées puisqu'il
s'agissait de personnes avant tout qui
soit administrateurs au cadre dirigeant
dans ces entreprises
me demandait également le détail
donc les relevés de compte de ces
comptes bancaires me demander également
à ces assez largement le détail des
factures téléphoniques c'est-à-dire des
postes qu'ils avaient appelé ou des
appels qu'ils avaient reçu
l'identification donc de ces numéros il
me demandait également défilatures des
surveillances ça ce qui est rentré dans
le cadre légal de la profession d'agent
privé de recherche
et puis il me demandait aussi des
renseignements administratifs qui
pouvaient être contenus dans les dans
les mairies
office que dans les fichiers de police
pour savoir si ces gens avaient été
condamnés ou avaient fait l'objet de
procédure Patrick Battendier balance il
n'hésite plus aujourd'hui à raconter les
dessous d'une guerre éc secrète ou les
détectives privés sont en première ligne
comme par exemple en Afrique dans la
compétition que ce sont livrés Vincent
Bolloré et Jacques Dupuis Dobby pour le
contrôle du Port de Lomé une affaire qui
remonte à 2005 à l'époque le groupe
Bolloré souhaite avoir le contrôle de
tous les ports en Afrique et le port de
Lomé au Togo et dans sa ligne de mire
seul hic il appartient au groupe Progosa
de Jacques dupuidoby le rival de
toujours Patrick battendi explique
aujourd'hui qu'il a été engagé en 2005
par GEOS une société d'intelligence
économique qui aurait été commanditée
par le groupe Bolloré selon Battendier
il aurait eu pour mission d'obtenir
toutes sortes d'informations
déstabilisantes sur le principal rival
depuis Dobby ou sur un de ses plus
proches collaborateurs
le but était en fait de déstabiliser le
groupe Progosa par l'intermédiaire de
Monsieur Gérard Perrier qui avait été
lui qui avait eu quelques démêlés avec
avec la France et bien évidemment la
stratégie était stratégie des
informations et de déstabilisation et
elle a abouti elle est allée jusqu'au
bout puisque en fait on désinformant ils
ont réussi grâce aux renseignements que
j'avais confié géo ça a réussi à les
transférer donc à Bolloré qu'il a et
l'autre ou l'un ou l'autre on fait
paraître ces éléments dans la presse
togolaise dans un hebdomadaire qui
s'appelait d'ailleurs le combat du
peuple voilà et donc c'est à Paris en
première page en première page il y
avait la copie du jugement de Gérard
Perrier donc bien évidemment
l'information noire qui est arrivé là au
grand jour par rapport à une stratégie
de déstabilisation qui avait été en
toute
en toute
en toute logique demandée par le groupe
Bolloré rattrapé par la justice Patrick
battendit a déjà passé quatre mois en
prison alors aujourd'hui il préfère
révéler les pratiques de son métier au
grand jour plutôt que d'être un fusible
anonyme Patrick Battendier veut dénoncer
toute l'hypocrisie d'un système opaque
pratiquement la loi qui arrangerait tout
le monde à commencer par les services de
renseignements officiel de l'État la DST
avec qui Patrick Battendier le détective
privé dit avoir été en contact régulier
pour échanger des informations je suis
inquiété de plusieurs chefs d'incubation
un qui est en fait
[Musique]
la corruption fonctionnelle comme si on
le fonctionnaire parce que me dit-on à
quelques reprises à deux ou trois
reprises j'ai fait appel à mes anciens
collègues gendarmes pour leur demander
l'identification d'une plaque
minéralogique pour leur demander la
confirmation d'une adresse donc pour
leur demander la copie d'un jugement
auprès du tribunal de Paris voilà
ce qu'on oublie ce qui a oublié de faire
étrangement parce que oublier la justice
de faire c'est étrangement c'est
également de m'occuper pour la
corruption de fonctionnaires des
fonctionnaires de la DST puisque c'est
eux qui me fournissaient la majorité de
mes renseignements moi j'espère
sincèrement que un juge digne de ce nom
lors du procès
s'interrogera sur sur le déroulé de
l'enquête et voudra entendre les clients
finaux qui voudraient entendre les géos
l'écroule qu'il voudra réentendre les
gens de la DST sans aucun favoritisme
cette fois-ci qui ne voudra faire la
part des choses
de façon très procédurale et très très
droite
[Musique]
peut-être est-ce que c'est un peu
vous êtes est-ce que c'est un peu
illusoire de penser comme ça puisque
pendant toute cette affaire ce que j'ai
pu voir c'est un pouvoir exécutif et
couvrir et à pouvoir judiciaire couvrir
des balversations faites par une
institution qui se devait apparemment
selon le président de la République être
irréprochable
le procès de Patrick Battendier devrait
avoir lieu en 2010 mais ce procès est
une épine dans le pied pour la justice
l'affaire battendiez est un cas d'école
pour toute la profession de détective
privé si il a obtenu pardon des
renseignements confidentiels de la part
de service public il appartient à la
justice des déterminés s'il y a
violation des secrets professionnels de
la part de ses services publics si
lui-même a donné des informations
confidentielles sur les affaires qu'il
traitait pour le compte de certaines
agences géos
crawl je crois
et bien il appartiendra à la justice de
déterminer lui-même a violé le secret
professionnel et si les services publics
ou les officiers de police judiciaires
qui ont obtenu ces informations qu'il
n'auraient pas dû donner qu'il
n'auraient pas dû donner
son coupable ou pas de recettes de
violation de secret professionnel en
tout cas moi personnellement c'est pas
la peine qu'on vient de me demander des
renseignements sur mes clients je n'en
donnerai pas
depuis les révélations de battantiers
les affaires de barbouseries font de
nouveau la une de l'actualité dernière
en date EDF et Greenpeace une enquête
est en cours pour déterminer si EDF un
mandaté un cabinet d'enquête privée une
officine pour espionner Greenpeace en
2006 un pirate informatique un hacker
aurait même été engagé afin de
surveiller plus de 10 ordinateurs de
l'association écologiste le poêle à
gratter de l'énergie nucléaire en France
l'actuel président de Greenpeace Pascal
lusting est un peu surpris des privés au
service d'EDF c'est plutôt inattendu
ce qui nous étonnerait pas c'est si
l'entreprise d'État EDF se tourner vers
les services de renseignement des états
les RG la DGSE pour en savoir plus sur
une organisation qui met en doute
l'idéologie nucléaire en France sans
nous étonnerait pas parce qu'en plus on
est voilà on est grippe et toujours
toujours en face de ce type de ce type
d'interaction avec les renseignements
généraux et c'est quelque chose qui qui
participe même éventuellement du jeu
démocratique par contre ce qui nous
étonne gravement c'est le fait que EDF
encore une fois une société qui opère 58
réacteurs nucléaires en France se
tournent vers une officine bas de gamme
et que EDF prenne un risque de se faire
voir de se faire avoir par une officine
de barbouze question pourquoi EDF
aurait-elle fait appel à une ligne
privée très discrète jusqu'à présent sur
cette affaire l'entreprise que nous
avons sollicitée à plusieurs reprises
nous a renvoyé vers son avocat Maître
Gublin au passage l'avocat va nous
expliquer une particularité bien
française
il n'est pas dans l'habitude des DF de
recourir à des officines privées pour
une raison simple c'est que EDF à
l'avantage en qualité d'anciennes
entreprises d'État d'avoir la
possibilité de bénéficier des services
éthiques je m'explique s'agissant de la
sécurité et de la sûreté nucléaire EDF
bénéficie d'un contrat tout à fait
particulier avec la gendarmerie
nationale et c'est la gendarmerie
nationale par exemple qui assure la
sécurité sur les sites appartenant à EDF
ce qui est unique au monde EDF est la
seule entreprise au monde à avoir
recours à ce type de procédé c'est à
dire à s'appuyer sur un appareil d'État
il en est exactement de même en ce qui
concerne l'acquisition de l'information
le renseignement puisque là encore EDF
bénéficient de toutes les possibilités a
été offerte par l'État c'est à dire
essentiellement les services de la DCRI
de la DGSE éventuellement de la DRM donc
toute la partie
côté sécurité est assurée par l'État à
partir de ce moment-là nous n'avons
aucune raison de recourir à des
officines privées aucune comment se
fait-il alors que l'affaire éclate avec
une officine privée bien écoutez il
appartiendra au juge d'instruction de
révéler la vérité dans cette affaire
nous depuis le début nous souhaitons
coopérer avec la justice ce qui apparaît
aujourd'hui comme étant une évidence
c'est que deux salariés n'ont pas de
salariés des DF n'ont pas respecté les
règles internes et ont passé ce contrat
en violation des règles internes à
l'entreprise aujourd'hui je ne peux pas
vous en dire plus si il appartiendra au
juge de mettre éventuellement d'autres
faits en avant
cette affaire a en tout cas révélé que
les agences de renseignements privés et
les détectives privés n'hésite pas à
recourir aux pirates informatiques
rendez-vous pris chez Lexy leader
français de la sécurité des plus grandes
entreprises de l'Hexagone société créée
par un ancien de la DGS
[Musique]
la technique des pirates est celle du
cheval de Troie le malware un programme
informatique introduit à distance par un
pirate dans les ordinateurs ciblés et
qui permet la surveillance de tout
système informatique en temps réel
offensif un malware
il peut effectivement leur collecter
toute la messagerie peut collecter les
appels vocaux donc virtuellement toute
la stratégie de l'entreprise s'active
ces éléments commerciaux etc enfin parti
un moment où on est sur le poste après
il y a juste le temps de traitement de
toutes les informations qui sont
collectées
mais
bien sûr enfin ce que j'ai c'est ça
change la vulnérabilité de nos systèmes
d'information de manière générale dans
la société qu'on utilise des téléphones
des postes etc des réseaux elle évolue
avec toutes les techniques aujourd'hui
le malware évidemment une opportunité
d'espionnage c'est c'est une évidence
c'est un boulevard pour l'espionnage
[Musique]
désormais toutes les techniques les plus
sophistiquées de l'espionnage sont à la
disposition des détectives privés et les
agents de recherche privée travaillent
de plus en plus pour de grands groupes
industriels qui ont beaucoup d'argent et
parfois guerre économiques oblige peu de
scrupules
en France réglementer la profession et
ses pratiques c'est devenu presque une
urgence
pour tous ceux qui ont franchi la ligne
jaune et qui attendent un procès c'est
l'occasion de sortir de l'ombre pour
expliquer qu'ils sont eux aussi les
victimes d'un système
en France on fait tout en dessous
tout le monde ferme les yeux et
bien souvent la presse dévoile certaines
zones certaines opérations certaines
opérations complètement douteuses et
foireuses et tout le monde s'étonne
comment comment est-ce possible dans
notre pays encore c'est encore possible
parce que
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui a une société
de renseignements privés
il faut bien qu'ils vivent donc derrière
il essaie d'utiliser tous les moyens qui
lui sont permis et peut-être plus pour
obtenir du renseignement et pour vendre
du renseignement pour avoir le
renseignement dans le privé c'est une
partie d'échec il faut toujours avoir un
coup d'avance et pour avoir un coup
d'avance il faut avoir le renseignement
que l'autre n'a pas pour être pour avoir
une plus-value pour pourquoi un cabinet
d'agent privé de recherche plus demander
que l'autre parce qu'il va obtenir le
renseignement que l'autre n'obtiendra
pas aujourd'hui cette profession est
totalement fou alors pour moi elle est
totalement fou un agent privé de
recherche aujourd'hui c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui est totalement qui est
borderline en permanence donc
quelle serait la solution alors la
solution à mon sens c'est d'en faire des
auxiliaires de police avec une mission
bien définie utilisable par des cabinets
de d'avocats par des sociétés vraiment
il faudra que cette profession soit
totalement
transparente avec des avec une avec un
code bien bien défini en liaison avec
les forces de police
comme ça je pense que ça sera beaucoup
plus simple pour tout le monde il y a
une nécessité d'avoir certains
renseignements détenus par
l'administration française
encore une fois il ne faut pas ouvrir
tous les fichiers à cette profession
simplement leur permettre de travailler
par rapport aux besoins
qu'ils peuvent avoir sur une enquête
précise
c'est voilà comme ça peut se faire aux
USA comme ça peut se faire dans d'autres
pays qui ont compris que dans quel privé
était également
l'ami de l'enquête publique
retour à Melun le jour de la remise des
diplômes universitaires et des licences
de la dernière promotion d'agents de
recherche privée en tout 39 lauréats
[Musique]
dans quelques instants
récompenses des efforts
les efforts passés dont vous pouvez être
parfaitement fier
[Musique]
Céline a réalisé son rêve à 38 ans elle
va commencer une nouvelle carrière
Christelle la spécialiste en œuvre d'art
n'a pas peur elle de la concurrence dans
son domaine c'est la seule diplômé
certains d'entre eux ceux qui ont une
licence vont même pouvoir demander
l'agrément en préfecture pour se mettre
à leur compte et peut-être accrochez le
précieux sésame au-dessus de leur bureau
deux ans d'investissement
on va dire ouais deux ans de sacrifice
de vie perso parce que pendant deux ans
aucun weekend je vais faire de nous les
enquêteurs de demain et même
d'aujourd'hui pour le coup parce que moi
je suis déjà en poste mais voilà ce que
je retiens c'est que
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
ça évolue comment ils recherchent mes
mots je suis désolé mais c'est ça évolue
dans tous les sens du terme ça évolue
dans l'enseignement ça évolue dans la
pratique je pense que tant que ce sera
fait comme c'est fait aujourd'hui
voilà ça y est ça ira dans le bon sens
l'avenir pour nous bah c'est bah voilà
maintenant c'est
c'est mettre nos connaissances en
pratique c'est
[Musique]
sûrement dans un avenir à moyen terme
peut-être aussi de nouvelles
perspectives de pour l'enquêteur privé à
travers le complément d'enquête pénale
avec la fin du
[Musique]
c'est
c'est des collaborations peut-être plus
étroite maintenant entre avocats et
enquêteurs
puisque c'est quand même un métier qui
voilà petit à petit va être reconnu pour
ses compétences juridiques
[Musique]
tous ces nouveaux professionnels vont
aller chercher du travail dans les
quelques 1500 agences de recherche
privée qui existent en France
et leur professeur les déontologues de
la profession
espèrent bien que ces jeunes diplômés
donneront enfin ces lettres de noblesse
à un métier en pleine mutation